let's begin we're looking at multimedia
that's always starting on okay so you
guys know I really like to get out where
words come from they help us to
understand things so before we look at
multimedia let's look at the part of
this word right so multi I think you
guys know what multi means just means
thank you more than one right okay
multiple is where we get that word that
media media as you probably recognize
media is a plural it's a plural of thank
you oh no we actually dealt with this a
little while ago but let's just revise
it the word medium what was it actually
referred to what kinds of contexts do we
see the word medium come up in well
there's a TV show called medium right
what's that about yeah my reader she can
sort of access you know this other world
she's got cheese the menu I know some uh
where else do we see this we usually
call it a size right is small and then
there's medium and then there's large
sorry large so what is media mean it
just means in between right so we're
going to talk about the TV show right
that that the main character the
protagonist she's a medium between you
know us normal human beings and this
other sort of spiritual world which
other people can't sense
so she's the in-between person and he
our medium as a size just means is in
between small or large right that's
that's all medium it's in between okay
now that's what a medium is what's media
and in the context of of course what are
we talking about right is any way or
anything that could be in between two
others right and so specifically we're
thinking about data and communications
and been sending data through from a
data source to you and the medium is
what's in between that make sense
I'm so for instance right now you're the
medium that we have for you to the
computer that that I'm drawing on right
now is a screen that's the me right now
I'm heading back to you look over here
there are five basic kinds of media by
the way just be careful when you're
using plural singular
Media is the plural word what are the
five basic kinds of media now I'll admit
this is a little bit confusing at first
but I hope you'll see why it makes sense
it's really really similar to the five
basic datatypes with a couple of crucial
differences so let's just revise there's
five kinds of data what are they
let's go from simplest to most complex
what's the first one in America good
okay we have numbers followed very
shortly by text and then these three are
kind of different they're much bigger
where we go first yeah good pictures and
then the stuff that you hear right so
that's all your own and then the last
one the most complicated of all of them
is video right which we would say is
composed of audio and lots and lots of
images yeah okay now there's the data
types we let this right at the beginning
of the course the five kinds of
multimedia are almost the same it's
slightly different I'll show you the
five media types look like this and I'll
explain the second why or maybe you can
work out why this has changed numerical
and text okay I want to tell you that
media they get rolled into one
okay numerical text in much the same way
do you remember when we're looking at
databases we said that all three of
these guys right they get rolled into
one
type do you member what they were called
at a funny name they were called blobs
right binary large objects okay so in a
similar sort of way your miracle and
text get rolled into one media
here the next three are just these three
image audio-video okay so that's also
there's one left where we come from
you're probably thinking oh no that
looks pretty comprehensive to me the
fifth and last media type is animation
now you might be wondering why does
animation end up on its own right why is
it separated off from say video right
well it's a little bit different as
you'll see in a second question yeah
okay okay going alright now for each of
these and I'm going to get you guys to a
brainstorm the second we'll come back
together when you think about each of
these media types we just looked at
they've got particular features and
strengths okay and therefore I'm sorry
on the flip side they also have
limitations and drawbacks and those two
in combination they mean we pick certain
diet eyes for certain things okay you
when you're trying to convey information
right that's what a medium is for
sometimes the most fitting type will be
numerical text other times you go for an
image sometimes you go for some
combination that's why we say multimedia
right sometimes video is the best and if
you try to convey something that's good
for video to your numerical texas be
really really inappropriate okay so let
me just give you let's start off by
saying what are some of the really
obvious advantages disadvantages for
each of these types let's just think
about this well some of them go together
for instance audio and video one of
their main disadvantages is size
compared to the rest of the data types
they're huge right orders of magnitude
larger okay thousands of times larger
American text they're the most efficient
okay
but there's some disadvantages to those
as well right
Numerical vixx they're not very engaging
sitting down and reading is a
time-consuming process and it can often
be very boring right depending on what
kind of thing has been written but I
hope you can see each of these kinds of
drawbacks right they also have their own
strengths so even though we might say on
your miracle text it's not super
exciting doesn't grab you when you look
at a page of text all right you think
well text wall you know that kind of
thing but actually what are the great
things about the textile type
it can convey a lot of detail in a very
compact space right you see how that's
sort of the opposite of this size thing
it's very very small in data size you
can convey lots and lots of detail very
precisely okay audio and video of course
by contrast to numerical texts they're
really interested in saying if you want
to convey something grab people's
attention maybe if you're marketing
things right audio video you're far more
effective okay which is why if you look
at advertisements even in say a
newspaper right which we would think is
more of this end of a scale those kinds
of investments they're going to heavily
use images because it grabs people right
you're looking through your piecing
through and you think you're all that
grabs my arm now these aren't the only
ones there are other particular purposes
you can think about for the other media
types and why so I'm going to get you
guys to think about that for a little
while and then we're going to look
particularly at animation so I'll give
you a few minutes